great you look fabulous now it's time to
vogue into the house of vegas okay we
have we have our summer pride fest
coming up august 18th through the 21st
and to do the fabulous inviting we have
courtney
and
gorgeous salem
gucci correct and nicole you are the
founder of the pridefest as well so
we'll get to that in a minute but let's
talk about the
ballroom scene and just explain what
that means to the culture let's start
with you courtney well um to me
personally the muslim is a lot to me um
it's a safe place for lgbtq plus
community people um to come and showcase
their talents and just have a safe space
i love that and it is basement dance
rooted in dance there's a lot of
different categories you have fashion
you have um a runway category you even
have some beauty categories that
everybody can partake in but yes dance
is a huge part of it as well you guys
are all winning the beauty category
that's right okay okay so let's talk
about um
the the festival nicole you're the
founder why did you why did you bring
this to the community and what can we
expect well it was definitely called for
las vegas there was a missing element
here to las vegas for the urban lgbtq
community so the weekend on the 18th to
the 21st is jam-packed with celebrity
hosted events with different themes like
the summer pride ball a music festival
mama d from the love and hip-hop atlanta
and miss pooh
amongst the many other organizers and
pride organizers that are coming to las
vegas to have some fun in the fabulous
city of las vegas and that's vegas
pridefest.com for your for more
information tickets and all that
vegas pridehouse.com ah vegas
pridehouse.com get it right okay so
we have about a minute and i cannot have
you fabulous ladies up here without
getting into it
have you listened to the renaissance yet
yes you gonna play it i'm alien
superstar
okay now how is the what is the proper
way to vogue uh there's 45 seconds to
show us what you got five elements
catwalk douglas hands performance spins
and dips and
okay what are you going to teach me well
you can start off with catwalk okay and
it's just up here there's no wrong way
to do it oh there's no deal no wrong way
it's going wrong okay okay
yes one yes
period
hands performance
hand hands you know it's like fluid hand
performance yes i love this because you
can literally do anything
however you feel yeah
i'll just flow
but you are the founder so one more time
that website vegas pridehouse.com and
please follow us on how to vegas prize
instagram for all the information too
much to talk about y'all